so this is a short addendum to the Trump
phone call transcript memorandum a thing
that is going on this is just so funny I
told you in our discussion of the bogus
summary of the Trump phone call with the
Ukrainian president that if the White
House thinks that the summary is not
incriminating just imagine how bad the
full transcript would be if it were
released there is a new report out now
that Donald Trump was incredulous and
shocked earlier this week that when he
sent a transcript of the phone call to
Nancy Pelosi she didn't read it and
immediately call off the impeachment
inquiry this is how out of touch the guy
is how disconnected from reality do you
have to be to send something to Nancy
Pelosi that confirms everything that has
been reported is true or at least it
certainly doesn't disabuse anyone of
that belief and then you're shocked that
Nancy Pelosi didn't read it and say you
know what now that I've seen what Donald
sent over I'm gonna cancel the entire
impeachment inquiry it's also
interesting that there are reports from
close to Trump that even though he
believes impeachment might help him
politically in 2020 he still doesn't
want to be impeached and we'll talk more
about that when things settle down a
little bit around the whistleblower
report but the real amazing thing here
is the degree to which Donald Trump
believes that he is endlessly convincing
think back this is a personality trait
that made Trump say a year ago or
whenever sure I'll sit down with Robert
Muller that's no problem I'll go talk to
him in person
Trump believes that he is so convincing
that he is so charismatic that he is so
articulate and a quick thinker on his
feet that people can't tell that he's
lying that he can just get in a room
with whoever and he can say something or
he can show something in this case a
transcript to Nancy Pelosi and that they
will be immediately overwhelmed by what
he is saying or showing them and they
will come over to his point of view and
thus he was stunned according to this
report that Nancy Pelosi didn't
immediately cancel the impeachment
inquiry because of what Donald Trump
sent her just another little notch in
our understanding
of how Donald Trump operates and it
certainly is consistent with everything
that we've seen so far